So thanks for having us back.
Um, it's nice to get reinvited.
It means we didn't do so poorly
the first time around. Um,
so my name is Louis Johnson and I am
most recently a rocky Vista University,
which is a very small
medical school in Colorado,
but I until recently worked
at University of Washington.
So I'm very happy to be back in the
region and joining some rain again. Um,
so today we're going to be talking about
our book and the first thing we want to
talk about is why would we write a
book about worries? So this is, um,
a picture of my daughter,
um, a couple of years ago.
She's much more advanced these days.
Um,
but I think for me,
I've always been kind of a worrier,
a worry wart. Anyway,
you want to phrase it.
I've always been stressed
out about things,
but this really accelerated as a
problem for me when I had kids.
Um, I don't know if anybody
else has had this experience,
but I realized when I had kids that there
was like new categories of things that
I had never even thought about that I
needed to worry about all of the sudden.
And as I would Google them,
I would get a little stressed out because
you get a thousand hits for anything
that you could potentially
be worried about. And um,
it started to really become kind of a
problem in my life that I was worrying
about all of these things.
And my husband said to me one day as I
was freaking out about something trivial
in retrospect, um, that, you know,
as a scientist you could probably figure
out what you need to worry about and
what you don't. And I had this
realization that that was actually true.
And so I started,
um,
to kind of investigate in a logical way
the things that I thought were important
to worry about and the things
that I didn't think were
important to worry about.
And as I was in this process,
I realized lots of other people are
stressed out about lots of things as well.
Um, and that kind of kicked
off this process. And then, um,
I worked with Eric Chudler at the time
and he graciously agreed to work on the
project with me.
And that's kind of how we got started.
But one of the things that I've noticed
is that this is an extremely timely
topic. Every time I tell someone, Hey,
I'm writing this book about worries,
they always respond with, did you write
a chapter on fill in the blank, right?
Everybody has something that
they're really worried about.
So we're going to talk about some of the
things that we discuss in the book and
then we're going to give some tips on
how people can investigate worries on
their own. But first we want to talk
about what our methods were. Um,
so Eric and I are both scientists and
I would venture to say kind of nerdy
scientists at that.
And so we felt that we needed to have a
process and some defining principles as
we embarked on this project.
So we thought about,
well what sorts of things should
you reasonably be worried about?
And we said there are really three
things that are important to consider.
The first is how likely is
something to happen to you. Um,
the second is how bad is it going to
be if it does in fact happen to you?
And then finally, what can you do
to prevent it from happening to you?
And we decided really that if
something is likely to happen to you,
if it's going to be bad,
and if you can do something about it,
then that sort of forms this magic,
um,
space of things that you should
worry about everything else.
If it's unlikely you don't
need to worry about it.
If it's not really going to be a big deal,
you don't need to worry about it.
And if there's nothing
you can do about it,
even if it is really
going to be a problem,
then you don't really need
to worry about that either.
Cause there's nothing that you
can really do to prevent it.
So it's kind of a waste of your time.
So we quantified,
quantified our worries in this way.
So for each of our problems
that we investigated,
each of our topics that we investigated,
we created what's called what we call it,
the worry index.
So the index is really a
very loose quantification.
Okay? It's really based on,
we investigated this,
we talked about it,
and we scaled each of these
worries with respect to each other.
So it's not something to really
take religiously to the bank.
It's a good place to start. And so
we're going to talk about, um, how we,
how we feel about each of these topics
and hopefully we'll have a chance for you
guys to participate as well.
So, as an example, uh, we're going
to talk about asteroid strikes.
So that's one of the things that
some people worry about in fact,
millions years ago is the dinosaurs were
maybe worried about getting struck by
an asteroid if they had a large enough
brain to worry about things. Uh,
but some people do worry about,
uh,
maybe all life on earth
will be destroyed again.
And so I'm going to give this in this
example about the criteria that we use and
then we're going to give you
some examples to do on your own.
So for an asteroid strike,
um,
the likelihood of getting struck
by a large asteroid is minuscule.
So there are a couple of centuries systems
here in the United States and also in
Europe that are scanning the skies for
large objects on their way to earth.
And it's estimated that the
next significant one within
the next hundred years
has almost a 99.9% chance
that it will miss earth.
So the likelihood of a large asteroid
hitting the earth is almost nil.
Okay? So because it's unlikely
nothing to worry about,
so you should be happy about that.
Very unlikely.
Can you do anything to prevent it?
So if there was an asteroid
coming to earth goes,
there's some way that you can avert this
disaster. So how many of you have seen,
uh, what is it, uh, uh,
Armageddon with Ben Affleck
and Bruce Willis? Yeah,
most of you have seen that
one, right? Would that work?
No, it's not going to work.
If you put a nuclear bomb on an asteroid,
you just,
instead of one asteroid
coming down to earth,
you're going to get maybe a 101
and it will still be a big problem.
We do not have any technology at
this time to prevent an asteroid.
If it was coming toward us,
some technologies that are being thought,
well maybe if you can break it
up into tiny, tiny little pieces,
maybe that would work.
Because our atmosphere is being
bombarded by asteroids all the time.
But they're small enough,
they burn up in the atmosphere.
It doesn't cause a problem.
Uh,
other technologies might be descend
something up and rather than a break it
apart, just nudge it a
little bit off course, right?
Because if you catch it soon
enough because the earth is moving,
all you have to do is change their
trajectory a little bit and the earth will
move out of the way. Right?
So they asked or the,
so the asteroid won't hit
another technology would
be to put up a large object
and gravitation only pull the asteroid
away again to divert it off course.
And that would also cause him
to miss. Can we do that now? No.
So we can't do anything to prevent it.
So nothing to worry about.
Now if it did happen though,
sorry if it does happen,
just like it happened
millions of years ago,
it would wipe out a lot of life on earth
and cute, including all human life.
All right, so the consequences devastated,
right? If something like that happen,
all human life would probably be
destroyed. All right? So unfortunately,
so when you add all these up together,
this is where we would place
it on that lower left side.
It's unlikely to happen.
There's nothing you can do about it.
I'll do the consequences would be bad.
But because of those two criteria,
getting struck by an asteroid is
nothing for you to worry about. Okay?
So those are the methods we use.
We looked at the data of the likelihood,
the consequence,
and can you do anything to prevent it?
Uh, so now, uh, it's a sort of
audience participation time.
So all of you should have a
piece of paper with a little,
a graph on it, a little plot. And a,
your job is to assign a little dot
and the size of the.is going to be the
consequence. And you should be
plotting it, uh, on the to scale.
So at least it's going to
introduce the first one.
Hmm.
Okay. So the first thing we're
going to talk about is mercury.
So everybody play along. It's after lunch.
So everybody wake up. Participation is,
is key.
Um,
I want you on your plot to make a bubble
sort of relative to the size that you
think it should be. And then
also too, uh, oh yeah, exactly.
Eric put up this nice plot.
So put it in at the quadrant that you
think it belongs in and then give it a
size relative to the magnitude of
the problem that you think it is.
I'll give you just a minute to do
that and then, um, we'll continue.
Everybody has to play commit.
Okay. So raise your hand if you think that
it belongs in this quadrant down here.
Unlikely.
And you can't do anything to stop it.
Excellent.
How about unlikely? And you can do
something about it. Yes. Excellent.
Some people think so likely to happen,
but you can't do anything about it.
This is sort of the fatalistic category
down here. A few. And how about up here?
Likely to happen. You need,
you can do something about it.
Therefore you should worry. Okay. Some
of you aren't playing, but that's fine.
You'll get into it. So
here's where we put it. Okay.
So we actually put it up here in the
word category and it gets a relatively
large dot. So why is that?
I kind of primed you.
I'm thinking about this by
giving you a picture of a fish.
So many people are thinking about methyl
mercury, which is part of our diet,
and we worry about it in that sense.
And that is a problem.
But there's also another form of mercury
that you might encounter and that would
be elemental mercury. So how many people
have actually seen mercury in real life?
Yeah, so it's very cool, right?
My mom tells me stories about when
she was a kid in science class,
they would actually give her a blob
of mercury to roll around in her hand.
And it was, is so exciting because
it's silvery and it's neat, right?
Everybody thinks it's neat and people
have thought that it's neat for thousands
of years actually. So historically
it's been used for medicinal purposes.
It used to be a very common treatment
for syphilis for example. Um,
it's been used for sort of magical or
ritualistic purposes and it still is,
it's used in mining because
it forms amalgams with both
gold and silver and it's
used in fillings, right? Does
anybody have silver fillings?
You probably all are gold fillings also.
You also have some mercury in there
because it forms an amalgam. Um,
so the problem with mercury that
in addition to being very cool,
it's obviously also very toxic, right? Um,
and mercury is most toxic,
not when you put it on your skin or even
when you eat it, but when you inhale it.
So elemental mercury is most
dangerous when you inhale it.
And which is strange because you don't
think about a metal is being particularly
vaporous, but mercury is a
strange metal, right? And so, um,
it's most easily absorbed into your body
if you inhale it and then it crosses
into your blood and then
it crosses into your brain.
And there are a number of negative
side effects associated with that.
So elemental mercury is very much to be
avoided and we don't usually encounter
it and commercial products anymore
that used to be in thermometers,
but they've been highly phased out.
Um,
and you used to find it in science
classes and fishing lures and all kinds of
places.
The problem is that even though we don't
manufacture those products anymore,
even though we don't describe,
distribute it to science classes for kids
to play with in the palm of their hand,
it's still exists in a legacy form.
Um,
and once it is distributed
in the environment,
once you break a thermometer,
once you spill mercury, it's very,
very difficult and expensive to
clean it up. You can't sweep it up.
You can't vacuum it up.
You can't just dump it down
the drain because it persists.
And there have been examples of children
finding it in their science classrooms
and taking it home and playing with
it and they have to take their houses
literally down to the studs in order
to decontaminate the house. Right.
There has been an example of somebody
who broke a mercury thermometer 20 years
prior in their home and they were still
recording measurable levels of Mercury
Vapor in the, in the, in the
room and the bathroom. Um,
so that can obviously be very problematic.
Methyl Mercury,
which we're familiar with in the term
in terms of fish, um, is also a problem,
but it's hard to say how
big of a problem it is.
And there's lots of confounders so
clearly having too much methyl mercury is
toxic and we know that because
of an unfortunate incident
in Minamata Japan, um,
a number of years ago.
Um, but it's sort of the,
in between levels are harder to quantify
because there are so many individual
differences and because consuming fish,
which is sort of the largest source of
methyl mercury is also really good for
you.
In lots of other ways.
So it's kind of this strange balance
between fish is really good for you and
your cognitive development,
but mercury is really bad for you
and your cognitive development.
So how do we find the,
the happy medium between those two things?
And I think it's fair to say that
scientists are still arguing about that,
but um, one thing we can say is that fish
that are higher up on the food chain,
which usually means the big ones,
right?
That eat the littler ones are going to
have more concentration of methyl mercury.
Then ones that are lower on the food
chain, which means if you eat sardines,
you're going to get less mercury than
if you're eating shark or swordfish,
for example. So most experts recommend
now that you should try and eat fish,
but you should eat fish.
They're lower on the food chain and fish
that are higher in omega fatty acids.
Okay,
so this one gets us a frowny face.
Yeah.
How do you think about the
scale along the x axis?
Is this a percentage chance of getting
hired and getting your lifetime or repeat
the question. Repeat the question. Sorry.
So how do we scale it on the x axis?
Is it sort of a lifetime risk?
I tend to think of it as more
of like a snapshot in time.
So at this point in time, if you, assuming
that you have any exposure at all,
like you are eating fish or you are
living in a world where there is elemental
mercury, what is your likelihood?
So it's a little bit personalized,
right? Not Everybody's going to
have the same level of exposure,
which is one of the reasons why we ask
people not to read too much into our
worry index, but related, think
about how this might apply to you.
Okay.
All right.
You're next worry is in honor
of a brain awareness week,
which is actually an international
event going on next week.
Is your brain eating Amoeba?
Uh,
and this was actually something that was
in the newspaper. I just very recently,
uh,
there was a case in Washington.
And so you may have seen the headlines
in Seattle times and on the news. So,
uh, again, on your sheets of paper,
where would this worry be?
Pick which quadrant it should be.
And again,
just to help you out,
looks like most people are finished.
So raise your hand if this
is a concern of yours,
that it's unlikely to happen and
there's nothing can do to stop it.
Unlikely that happen, but there's nothing
you can do to stop it. How about, uh,
the above that it's unlikely to happen,
but there is something you can do
about it. Maybe a few more people.
How about it's very likely to
happen to you. Uh, and you can,
uh, it's likely to happen and
you can't do anything about it.
So would likely it happened
that the bottom right hand side.
And how about just above that this is
something that you should worry about.
Alright, this is what replaced it. Uh,
it's something that is
very unlikely to happen.
There is something that
you can do about it,
but it has a large circle
because if it happens to you,
it's 97% fatal.
Okay.
So what is a brain eating Amoeba?
It's a small single celled
organism that is found in warm,
fresh water. Uh, if it's in
a inhaled, through your nose,
in many, not in many
cases, in a few cases,
it gets into the upper part
of your nose where it, uh,
then crawls, I guess if
an Amoeba crawls, uh,
through the sinuses up to your brain
where it starts eating brain tissue,
and that's bad as you might imagine.
Uh, but it's very unlikely to happen.
Many waters are contaminated
with this Amoeba,
but very few people come down with it. In
fact, for the last about 30 years or so,
there's only been about 150 cases or so.
So it's very unlikely to happen,
even though a lot of
water is contaminated. Uh,
you can also not contract the
disease by swallowing the water.
It must go into your nasal passages. So
it was just cause you swallow the water,
the Amoebas killed in
your digestive system. Um,
the other way you can get it if you don't,
if you're not in this fresh water in
like a spa or something like that. Uh,
there's a device called a Neti pot.
So some people use a Neti pot
to clean out their sinuses.
You're supposed to use
purified or sterilized water
and then you kind of tip the
pot into your nose to clean your sinuses.
Well, if that water is contaminated,
then the Amoeba can get up in your nose
and it can then crawl into your brain.
And I'm sorry to say kill you. Uh, so, uh,
again,
not something to worry about,
but the headlines make it as if it is
something that you should worry about.
The Seattle Times had a big
headline, you know, brainy didn't,
Amoeba doctor says it can happen to
you. Right? But very, very unlikely,
even though it's a somewhat common
bacteria, so nothing to worry about.
Uh,
the next one.
Okay, so flame retardants. First of all,
does everybody know what I mean
when I talk about flame retardants?
These are chemicals that are
added a lot of times to furniture,
most commonly furniture.
Also baby toys and bouncers and
stuff and carpets and car seats,
um, in order obviously to stop
him from catching on fire.
So now that you know what they are,
write down quickly what you think. Yeah,
no, that's a separate check.
Different chapter. Yeah. The risk
of being injured by flame retardants.
Yeah. So here's our, just to remind you,
here's our plot to put it
in one of these quadrants,
although that's an interesting question
about whether it's being injured by,
or the lack of both.
Obviously it could be a problem,
but in this case we're talking
about the chemicals. Okay.
So who thinks we belonged down here?
Not really a problem.
Okay.
How about up here?
A few as well.
So that would be in the unlikely
and you can do something about it.
So it's highly preventable,
but not highly likely.
How about it's likely to happen,
but you can't really do anything about it,
so don't worry about it.
Okay.
Okay. And how many think it's
something to worry about?
Okay.
So I'll tell you that this is the,
this is the topic that sent
me kind of over the edge. Um,
I was worried about flame retardants in
our sofa and I actually made my husband
take our sofa out to the garage and we
lived without a sofa for several months.
And I'll tell you why.
So before I do, let me,
let me show you where we assigned it and
explain a little bit about this plot.
Okay.
So first of all,
this circle right here is it looks
like it's slightly off to the left,
but it's meant to be centered right on
the 50% line and it's about 50% size.
Um, and that means actually when
I give something a score of 50 50,
it means I have no idea. Okay? So this is,
this is what I like to call in the
zone of the uncertainty. All right.
And the reason for that is because when
we're talking about flame retardant
chemicals,
there are thousands of different chemicals
that are out there in the wild that
are being used.
And most of them have actually not been
rigorously studied for their effects on
human health.
Okay.
So a little bit of history
on flame retardants. Um,
they were originally added to furniture
by law in the state of California around,
Oh, I'm gonna get my date
wrong. I think it was 1975. Um,
because there's a problem with people
smoking and when they fall asleep with a
cigarette in their mouth or close by,
they would like their furniture on fire.
And in order to get around this problem,
um,
the state of California mandated that
furniture meet a certain flame resistant
standard.
And the way that manufacturers achieve
to the standard was by adding flame
retardant chemicals. Um, and because
California is such a huge market,
most manufacturers didn't make furniture
for the rest of the world and furniture
for California, they just added flame
retardant chemicals to everything.
So the problem is that many of these
chemicals are associated with all kinds of
health problems. So enercon problems
and um, developmental problems,
growth problems.
Cancer obviously is always on the list,
but they haven't really
been, you know, the whole,
some of them haven't been
rigorously tested. Um,
and so we still don't really know
how big of a problem they are.
We know that they are persistent
environmental pollutants.
So you can isolate them in a f
in the fat of Arctic polar bears,
which turns out to be like the gold
standard for persistent environmental
pollutant. If you can find it in a
polar bear, then we have a problem.
Right? Um, and, and they're basically
everywhere in the environment,
which is why we get pretty
low preventability score
right there in your car.
They're in your house there or any place
that has foam in particular is often
treated with flame retardant chemicals.
So recently about 2013,
the state of California reversed.
It's a technical bulletin,
it's called technical bulletin one 17.
And now there's an amendment in 2013
saying you don't have to have um,
the same sort of flame retardant
properties and your furniture.
And so now it is legal to make
furniture that doesn't have added flame
retardants and some manufacturers do.
So you can find a sofa.
Ikea makes sense,
which is where we got our foot or non
flame retardant sofa is from Ikea.
And you can buy baby products that also
don't have flame retardants added to
them. Okay. It's probably
worth doing, in my opinion,
just because of the level of uncertainty.
But I can't say for sure that this is
going to hurt you or not hurt you because
the data is really not in on that.
Does that make,
does that sort of makes sense as to why
it ends up in this particular zone of
uncertainty? The other thing that
sort of surrounds this issue,
and it gets back to his question over
here about whether we should be concerned
about not having flame retardants.
So is there a problem with your
furniture catching on fire?
And the answer is probably yes.
Right?
Like we build our furniture and many
of the things that are in our house,
out of incredibly flammable materials
and foam in particular goes up really
fast. It Burns really hot and it
produces lots of really toxic smoke.
So that's obviously not ideal.
It turns out that in tests done by
the consumer product safety division,
uh,
sofas that were treated with flame
retardants didn't actually burn any less
quickly,
any less hot,
and they were a little bit more toxic
because of the added flame retardants.
Right?
So it's not that we don't have a problem
with our furniture catching on fire.
It's less of a problem now because fewer
people smoke in bed or in their couches
or whatever. Um, but we do have
incredibly flammable furniture.
It's just the flame returnings
don't really help with that problem.
So good news and bad news there.
So now as I promised you,
we're going to talk about some tips
for doing it yourself. Right? So, um,
the first thing I'll say is that
when we started on this project,
at least I thought that it was going to
be much easier to do than it turned out
to be because I thought, I have a
phd and I know how to read a paper.
I'll just go to the literature and I
will read papers and I will decide.
And it turned out to be really hard to do,
partly because it's really
hard to identify good sources
in a field that is not
your own field.
Right?
So we had to spend some time thinking
about how we really were going to identify
good sources and credible sources and then
come and sort of condense information.
So we came up with a tip sheet,
which we've actually included in the
appendix of the book and I'm going to give
it to you for free right here.
All my secrets right now.
So the first thing that I would suggest
is first to identify your priorities,
the things that you would like to worry
about. And that's because you know,
we created this worry index.
Um,
but it's based on what we
think is worth worrying about,
not necessarily what everybody else
thinks is worth worrying about it.
And everybody is different. Everybody's
individual. So you have to make your own,
um,
sort of priorities before you even start
because otherwise you can dig yourself
into a very deep hole very quickly.
Okay.
The second point is to
use credible sources.
And this is the part where I really
see people going wrong quickly.
I have seen many,
many poorly informed people on the
Internet spreading their ideas.
Okay? And it's not always
intentional. I think people,
there's a lot of misunderstanding,
but you don't want to take
somebody misunderstanding
and use it as the guide for
your life. Right? And that means
that you need to seek out expertise.
And we live in a time right now where
expertise is perhaps a little undervalued.
Um, and I think that's
unfortunate. I think that, um,
when people spend all of their time
and effort learning about something,
they probably have something
useful to say about it.
And we should seek out those people
when we're trying to make our decisions.
Anybody can have an opinion, but not
everybody's opinion is equally valid.
Okay. Um, the other thing that I
would say is to read laterally,
which is a new term to me,
so I'll just define it.
You might already be completely
familiar with it. So the idea is that,
especially on the Internet,
if you're reading vertically,
you're starting at the top and you're
reading down to the bottom right?
And that doesn't always give you as much
information about that source as you
would like.
So to read laterally,
what you do is you actually open a new
tab and then you search for the source
that you're looking at and see what
other people have to say about it, right?
Because the Internet being what it is,
there will probably be other people who
have thought about what that source is
and whether or not it's a reliable source.
And so whenever you're deciding whether
you should believe what you read,
you should think about who it
is that's telling you that,
why they're telling you that what their
credentials are for telling you that,
what their biases are behind that.
We usually recommend that people start
with government agencies and people don't
like to hear start with a
government agency, right?
But let me just say this.
The government funds
science out of public funds,
which means that the requirements
for transparency are very high. Okay.
Grants are reviewed by other scientist.
Papers are reviewed by other scientists,
governments,
um,
government labs that do research have to
post their data and make their methods
available. Okay? That is not the
case for private think tanks.
And it may not be clear where
their money is coming from,
why they're giving you that information.
So
think what you may about
government agencies,
but it's at least a very
good place to start.
So I always like the national
institutes of health.
There are multiple institutes of health.
They often produce fact sheets,
which are very helpful.
The Centers for Disease Control,
the World Health Organization,
while not being truly a
governmental agency is also
very reliable source and the
FDA as well.
Okay.
Seek out expertise and then
look for consensus in the field.
So I say this because I actually teach
it in medical school and I have my
students review scientific papers for me.
Um,
and I always have a student that reviews
a paper about the dangers of vaccines.
Okay.
And here's my point about that.
Vaccines Aren't covered in the book, first
of all. So my point about that is yes,
you can always find some scientific
literature that will review the risks.
And it's not that there aren't any risks
and it's not that those things aren't
worth investigating,
but you need to look at the entire body
of literature surrounding any topic
before you make a decision.
Okay?
There are lots of different
opinions in science and that's good.
There should be lots
of different opinions.
But when you're trying to figure out
sort of the global truth about a topic,
what everybody thinks is going to
settle closer to the truth than what any
individual thinks. So it's important to
think about what everybody is saying,
not just what one paper says.
One paper is never enough to
make a decision about anything.
Um, and then finally or not
finally, I have more next, um,
I would say understand probabilities
at least a little bit, okay?
Because scientists like to
speak and probabilities,
which can be very frustrating for people.
They want to know,
will this give me cancer or not?
Right?
But that's not how life works
because everything is multifactorial.
So everything has a probability or a
chance of impacting anything happening to
you. And a scientist will very
rarely say if you eat this,
you will die of cancer,
right?
They will say this will increase
your risk of dying of cancer. Okay?
So think about what that means,
really, how it applies to you,
how it applies to your
particular risk category, right?
Cause not everything is going to
apply to everybody in the same way.
I would say be skeptical and this is a
skill that we maybe have lost a little
bit,
right?
It's important for somebody to convince
you of why what they're saying is true,
right? First, when you hear
something, when somebody says to you,
you should definitely
panic about this right now.
Your first instinct should be why?
Why should I panic about that right now?
And if you give me a good reason, then
maybe a little panic about it, right? Um,
and then actually my last point is
I would say don't panic about it.
And that's how that's easier said
than done even for me, right?
I can stand here and say,
don't panic about it and then I'll go
home and have a little minor freak out
about something.
Right?
But for me and I think for everybody
it can help to make an action plan.
Right and do something about the things
that you can do something about and stop
worrying about the things that
you can't do anything about.
I'm not the first person
to have said that.
I'm just suggesting that you apply a
logical and rigorous method to thinking
about the things that
you want to worry about.
Would you like to add anything
doctor telling him. Okay. Okay. Um,
so at this point we have a couple of
minutes so we could go through a couple
more examples or we could go to questions.
Hi, I'm so I'm wondering
if you have anything to say
about the disconnect between
what you may logically understand is
something not to be worried about,
but I'm subconsciously
or against your logic,
you are worrying about it anyway.
And I think for a lot of people was
probably the size of the bubble is a
indicator of how much they'll worry about
it regardless of where it is on that
plot. So do you have any techniques for
how to let your logical thinking starts
overcome the worry?
Well,
I can tell you what works for me,
but I don't know that that
would work for everybody in.
Eric probably has a
comment on that as well,
although I don't think he
worries in general as much
as I worry about things. Um,
so for me this process actually really
helps to go through and look at what the
evidence is and then to make a conscious
decision and then remind myself every
now and then like I already decided
I'm not going to worry about flame
retardants cause I can't do anything
more about it. Um, you know,
but that doesn't,
that's not always enough for everybody,
especially if you tend to
be a hiring anxiety person.
And there are other techniques
obviously for just dealing with stress.
Like exercise is really good at reducing
people's stress level or meditating or
praying or you know,
a lot of other techniques.
The world is a stressful place and like
there's no way that you're going to
eliminate all of the things that could
potentially kill you or hurt you. Um,
so in,
in some sense you have to,
you have to come to grips with
that and whatever way you can.
So this can help to some extent,
but maybe not all the way.
That's what I would say.
Yeah. And you might
think to yourself, well,
why would someone have worry about a
particular thing if they're really,
logic doesn't point that direction.
And I think part of that reason is
because some of these things that happen
rarely. For example,
shark attacks. All right,
some people are afraid of
getting eaten by a shark.
How many people do think a
year get killed by sharks?
Just throw out some numbers.
305 in the entire world,
how many people do you think get attacked?
An unprovoked shark attack in the
world? What number? No, not killed.
Just attack the bitten by a shark. How
minute? Throw it in with some numbers.
That 50, 50, 10. Yeah. So now you're,
you're kind of going down now,
but it's about, it's about,
it's less, it's less, it's less.
It's less than a hundred
in the entire world.
I think of all the millions of
people that swim in the ocean,
yet people are afraid of
shark attack, right? Well,
it's because when a shark attack
does happen, it's horrific, right?
So the, every time a surfers surf
board gets chomped by a shark,
it's in the news,
right?
And so the media plays up these
things and plays on people's fears.
And so that might cause some
illogical fears and worries in people.
But when you look at the real data,
a lot of these things are
nothing to worry about.
Hi.
You mentioned that,
uh,
when I did research and I should
look at the entire body of science to
scientific literature,
not just read one piece,
but I think historically a lot of things
have been breakthroughs because they
were in the minority, are unique.
For example, with Darwin and Galileo,
I mean it's, and these people have
historically always been persecuted.
So I guess my question is like,
nowadays the people who are into,
uh, anti Max probably
feel that way, right?
And I can't convince them they're wrong.
And I
wondering how do I interact
with people who feel this way?
I feel like we have multiple
questions and there's,
let me see if I can
unpack them a little bit.
So first is the point about
science has always been, you know,
the minority is pushing it forward.
I don't,
I think that that's actually an
exception rather than a rule.
So it's notable when it happens because
it happens rarely, not all the time.
Right? Um, so yes, it
does sometimes happen.
So you have to acknowledge that sometimes,
you know,
everybody thinks there's an
ether and there's not. Right. Um,
but often science moves forward through
lots of small steps and a group of
people pushing something forward.
Right? Um, so that's the first thing.
The second thing is,
you're right,
you will never convince somebody
against their will, right?
If people have, you know,
people don't want to be wrong,
so there's only so much you
can do. And I think, um,
in some ways you have to just
be peace with that, right?
Like you can't convince
everybody all the time,
but you can only do what you can do about
yourself and make choices for yourself
and make choices for your
family. And that's, um,
at least my opinion on how to interact
with people. Um, I still try, I'm a,
I'm a huge sort of science advocate and
advocate for logical thinking and for
looking at data. Um, you know, the
day that our book was released,
I got an angry email from somebody
about fluoride, right? And there,
you know, I can't, I can't
change that person's mind.
It doesn't matter how much data
I show them, how much data,
people research that if you don't
want to believe it, you don't.
Quick Followup. You don't mind. You said
he can't change how other people are,
but you also said that you were
like, you advocate, thank you.
The scientific thinking.
I imagine you want to pass this
onto your children or your spouse.
And my question is, how do
I help my partner at us? Uh,
how do I help my partner worry less?
And I'm asking you for a friend.
So your friend's partner,
um,
it depends on your friend's
partner really. Um, I guess, um,
I would, I would try and stay
away from being judgy. Right?
So if you come to somebody with an open
mindset and an openness to talk about
things that you're going
to get a lot farther,
then if you come out of the gate
swinging is what I would say.
Maybe you have
no,
no.
And I think it's a lost skill that perhaps
we may not be able to change a adults
thinking,
but trying to culture critical
thinking skills in children and,
and young students. Perhaps that's the
one way we can combat some of this,
these false hoods that we know about.
Thank you. Thanks for speaking. Um,
I was wondering how like preventability
interacts with things that are like as a
group preventable,
but as an individual you can do very
little about like climate change as an
example that individual a,
we can almost do nothing but yeah.
Would be addressable if we,
if there were a group action.
So,
uh,
in the book we really only thought about
things you can do personally to prevent.
Um, obviously corporate action is
a much more difficult problem. Um,
and you know, I'm not, I'm not, I
don't have any great answers for that.
And I think like vote is obviously
a big one. Um, but not perfect.
And um, you know, community organization
and a number of other things. It's,
I that's a tough night.
That's the only thing.
Yeah.
That's the only thing that I thought of
is voting for the types of things that
you think uh, people should
be doing. Yeah. Vote.
Um, so my question might
be able to be collated.
I've noticed there are certain
cases where our warriors,
even though they own them,
unlike you cite the fact that
we are worried changes it.
So makes it unlikely.
Let me give an example.
Let's say turning America into
dictatorship. Theocracy. Anything goes.
It is not today.
It's not happening in the priorities low
because we worry about it all the time
because we kind of do something about it.
So if it's low,
right?
If you look at the probability
is low impact is high,
but it's low because of our worries.
What do you think about that?
I mean, so yeah. I mean,
when I see students that are about to
defend their dissertations and they're
really stressed out about it,
I'm like,
I'm not worried about you because
you're about it. And you know,
if you weren't worried about it than
I would be worried. And I think,
I think that's sort of
a similar situation. Um,
but I actually think that that means that,
that it is high on the
preventability scale. Right.
But it doesn't happen because it is
preventable and we take action against it
and that prevents it from happening.
But it's slow. The appropriate, well,
it's unlikely to happen because it's
highly preventable I guess is what I would
say.
Yes.
And that's actually interesting.
Perhaps that's a new chapter
for the book and that would be,
should you worry about worry
and the answer is probably yes.
Because we're in does have physiological
effects. It could reduce your sleep,
can cause stress,
which caused other physiological problems.
So we're in about worrying is probably
something that we should worry about it.
Thank you for do something
about it. Yeah. Yeah.
You mentioned about the, um,
government organizations, but you know,
we have some examples like Flint, you
know, crisis where they weren't truthful.
So how do you, um, look critically,
uh, government sources as well?
So I guess first of all,
I would distinguish between different
kinds of government organizations.
So when I'm talking about
governor government organizations,
I'm talking about research based
government organizations, um,
not necessarily city or government
officials that are enacting policy.
I think that's, that's slightly
different. Um, but again,
so I think government fact sheets are
good places to start and in some cases I
think they're good
places to finish as well.
But if it's something that
you're concerned about,
then there are other
resources and, um, you know,
there's other governments with
other, other facts sheets, right?
So that works as well.
So like the National Health Service in
the UK produces their own set of fact
sheets and you can compare, but then you
can also go to the primary literature.
And I think I try and caution people
when they do that because the chances of
misinterpretations if you're not part
of that field can be pretty high. Um,
but that's always an option that's
out there. There are online databases,
so Google scholar is the one that I
always use, but there's also pub men. Um,
and you can look there for primary
information and seek out those sources and
read them for yourself.
How do you guys factor in like return
on investment for preventability?
So something's very preventable.
But I'd have to sell my
home and moved to Alaska.
I know, I mean, so I think
that also the, so you,
that's where, why it's like a
three dimensional problem, right?
So it's very preventable,
but it's very unlikely.
Probably don't sell your house
and moved to Alaska. Right? Um,
you're increasing your odds of
getting eaten by a polar bear.
So you have to like really factor that
in as you're making that decision. Um,
and also the size of the
risk and just prioritizing.
Is it really that important to me that
it's worth making a major lifestyle
change?
And I think that's kind of what it comes
down to is get all of the data and then
say, well, what's, what's it worth
to me? And Is it worth the cost?
Is it really just a very
small marginal return,
or is it gonna make a huge difference in
my quality of life and nobody can make
that decision for you? You got to
get to do your own thing. Well,
thank you very much for
coming to talk to us today.